penguins and crushingly high g-forces
don't mix or at least they shouldn't but
in the batman the penguin escapes a
brush with death a little too easily
let's talk about that scene spoilers for
the batman ahead when the batman kicks
off bruce wayne has been patrolling
gotham for two years he's already
cemented himself as a brutal force on
the streets and he's created a sense of
paranoia in the city's criminal element
so whenever they see a symbol in the sky
they know he could strike from the
shadows at any moment he's a savage
fighter as seen in the film's opening
sequence with the skull-faced thugs who
target a passenger on the subway but
bruce isn't just up against petty
criminals in the 2022 film he's also
investigating a terrifying serial killer
called the riddler who goes after
corruption at the highest levels of
civil authority yes that's a strangely
heroic cause for a murderer who
terrorizes his victims with bizarre
traps and explosive collars gotham has
plenty of room for more than one
costumed vigilante since the city is
full to the brim with other criminals
it's not so surprising that the dark
knight meets some other iconic
characters over the course of the movie
chief among them is selena kyle aka
catwoman who is really more of an
anti-hero than a proper villain another
villain is notorious crime boss carmine
falcone who sits at the heart of
gotham's underworld last but certainly
not least is the charismatic oswald
cobblepot aka penguin a gangster who's
pulled into batman's investigation into
the riddler the penguin has quite a few
meaty scenes in matt reeve's first
batman flick but one of those scenes
doesn't really make any sense
one of the biggest action sequences of
the film sees batman chase the penguin
in a high-speed pursuit down the gotham
freeway after he suspects the mobster of
being an informant for the gcpd the
dramatic scene causes plenty of chaos on
the road and gives fans a look at what
the new batmobile is capable of it's one
of the best action sequences in the
entire film with the cinematography
dropping the audience right in the
middle of the swerving vehicles batman
even uses a ruined truck to ramp through
an explosion like a real comic book hero
and when he plows into penguin's car the
crash that results is brutal with the
mobster's vehicle spinning violently
through the air before he lands upside
down cabo pod is trapped in his car
unable to escape as batman walks toward
the wreckage
luckily penguin only has a few minor
injuries so batman and james gordon are
able to interrogate him afterward
without too much hassle so why is this
scene so troubling honestly because it's
more than a little shocking that penguin
isn't killed or at least leaving that
car in a stretcher considering how
disastrous the crash is the absurdity of
it kind of challenges our suspension of
disbelief even in a film where a grown
man dressed like a bat and acts
vigilante justice against a riddling
serial killer so why doesn't penguin die
in the batman
justice
the answer's justice it's not justice
but there are answers the first reason
is that from an effects perspective it's
just a fun cinematic way to show a car
crash you can ask the same question
about any modern action scene why
doesn't bruce wayne get whiplash when he
totals his lamborghini in the dark
knight how does anyone survive the fast
and furious movies it's about the
spectacle the other answer is even more
obvious colin farrell has more to do
with the role remember this is only the
second year of batman's crime fighting
career so there's still plenty of time
for cobblepot to become the version of
the penguin that dc fans know and love
the 2022 movie depicts him as an
up-and-coming crime boss underneath
carmine falcone and he's also in charge
of the sleazy iceberg lounge where
gotham's corrupt elite hang out most
nights
the film ends with a bit of a power
vacuum in the world of organized crime
it's highly likely that penguin will
climb the ranks to become the new crime
boss if warner brothers gives director
matt reeves green light for a sequel the
film's early reception has been
overwhelmingly positive so hopefully the
cast and crew get to come back for round
two but there's another key reason that
penguin isn't killed off in the film
he's getting his own tv series on hbo
max her variety the penguin show will be
executively produced by matt reeves
dylan clark and colin farrell hopefully
fans won't have to wait too long until
the streaming service reveals more about
what to expect from feral spin-off
series but until then we can all be glad
that this particular penguin is car
crash proof
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite bat movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]